my move University YouTube videos are
offered on a pay what you like basis if
you'd like to pay for the use of the
videos visit my website at move
university comm click on the pay what
you like link at the top of the page and
follow the instructions on that page
thank you and enjoy so previously we've
talked about fatty acid metabolism and
how we can break these fatty acids down
for energy and before we did that we
actually have to activate fatty acids
these two they're activated form called
a sole Koei's and the enzyme that did
that was called a SoCo a synthetase and
we added a coenzyme a and we that
required to ATP equivalents and we
talked about that in the previous video
where does this process actually occur
though this occurs in the cytosol of a
cell now where are these a sequoia is
actually broken down well they're broken
down via beta oxidation I mean a beta
oxidation occurs in the mitochondrial
matrix so we if that's the case then
these a souca ways upon activation have
to somehow get into the mitochondrial
matrix and mitochondria are cellular
bores or membrane bound organelles
excuse me and specifically they have two
membranes they have an outer membrane
and an inner membrane so membranes in
general are selectively permeable so how
do these asel Koei's actually get into
the mitochondrial matrix to be broken
down via beta oxidation well the answer
is in this title up here carnitine
mediated transport of a soakaway and i
want to write that all over again just
for time some see title so what is
carnitine and how does it work in this
sort of process well carnitine is this
molecule right here that I've drawn this
is carnitine and amino acid because it
has an amino group here in a carboxylic
acid it's not an alpha amino acid like
the ones that we've learned before but
it is an amino acid by definition
because it has an amino group and a
carboxylic acid group so what actually
needs to happen is this this acyl
portion of the a soakaway needs to be
attached to the hydroxyl portion this
hydroxyl group of carnitine to yield
this molecule and this molecule is
called creatively enough
carnitine so this acyl carnitine once
it's created can actually be transported
into the mitochondria so in this process
of taking this acyl group attaching it
to this carnitine and this coenzyme a
falling off we've created this acyl
carnitine and this process is catalyzed
by an enzyme called carnitine
acyltransferase that should make sense
right we're transferring an acyl group
in a circle from a soakaway onto
carnitine specifically its carnitine
acyltransferase one and we'll see that
there's another one later it can also be
called carnitine palmitoyl transferase
one or CPT one while this one's called
cat1 or cap one and I prefer to use the
acyl transferase instead of palmitoyl
transferase and the reason why is
because this can be any a SoCo a
palmitoyl refers specifically to a 16
carbon saturated fatty isoko a so I like
to use a ttle transferase one even
though this name works just as well so
now that we have this acyl carnitine
this thing can be transported in the
mitochondria so let's take a look at
that how that works now there's a little
bit of uncertainty here among among
scientists about exactly what happens
now this carnitine acyltransferase one
that I just mentioned that enzyme is
embedded in the outer mitochondrial
membrane so I've drawn it here and I've
drawn it here you might be wondering why
I drew it twice the reason why is
because there is initially a soak away
in the cytoplasm now we know that that a
soak away has to be or the acyl group of
that a soak away needs to be attached to
carnitine to make a so carnitine as we
just saw previously but it is unclear to
scientists whether or not that happens
outside in the cytoplasm or on the inter
membrane space side so that's why I've
drawn this gigantic or here so either
either this happens this left side
happens or this
side happens but we'll see that it's
either way we'll still be able to
understand this pathway so scenario one
right a SoCo a and the carnitine will
come together and form a so carnitine
where the catalyzed reaction occurs on
the cytoplasmic side of the outer
membrane of the outer mitochondrial
membrane still catalyzed by cat cat one
so we'll get this acyl carnitine and
this acyl carnitine can come in through
a channel protein or a pore that that
allows it to come through and then we
have acyl carnitine in the inter
membrane space either that happens or
instead of that happening a soakaway
comes right through the pore and then
joins carnitine and becomes acyl
carnitine and that reaction is catalyzed
on the inter membrane space side of the
outer mitochondrial membrane
notice that in either case we get acyl
carnitine in the inter membrane space so
this over here is just because
scientists aren't exactly sure at least
as far as I know about which one
actually happens but the point is though
that either way we get acyl carnitine in
the inter membrane space so once we have
acyl carnitine in the inter membrane
space what's going to happen this acyl
carnitine has to go from the inner
membrane space across the inner
mitochondrial membrane into the matrix
so what allows that to happen well
there's this transporter enzyme that's
abbreviated CAC T here and that stands
for carnitine carnitine acyl carnitine
translocase so what that thing does is
it can take the acyl carnitine from the
inter membrane space and transport them
across into the mitochondrial matrix so
now that we have this acyl carnitine
back in the mitochondrial matrix all we
need to do is split it back off to yield
RA so Co a so what happens is we're in
we're going to attach a coenzyme a to
this acyl carnitine so that we can get
back an acyl Co a and carnitine so what
catalyzes this reaction well before we
had cat one this one is cat 2 so that of
course stands for carnitine
acyltransferase 2 or you can put CPT to
write carnitine palmitoyl transferase 2
that catalyzes this reaction so now
we've regenerated this ahsoka way back
on the mitochondrial matrix side of
things right we just if effectively
carried the acyl group we've carried the
acyl group from the cytoplasm right
across the might of the outer
mitochondrial membrane and into the
mitochondrial matrix and now once is in
the mitochondrial matrix what can happen
well that process that we talked about
earlier right beta oxidation so that can
occur now what can happen is once this
carnitine a so Co a are regenerated of
course they soak away as we just
mentioned goes the beta oxidation but
this carnitine can be translocated back
across into the intermembrane space and
depending on which scenario actually
happens right it can either join another
a sub Co a and just be turned into a
acyl carnitine on the intermembrane
space side or if this process happens in
this carnitine will go back out into the
cytoplasm and join with another a so Co
a become acyl carnitine and come back in
to the intermembrane space so that the
process can all happen again so I hope
this name makes sense for this for this
translocase carnitine acyl carnitine
translocase because it translocates both
of these molecules it brings acyl
carnitine into the mitochondrial matrix
and kicks out these carnitine x' back
out so that they can join with another a
soakaway to make another acyl carnitine
so essentially what we're doing
essentially is we're just taking the a
souca waves from the cytoplasm and
bringing them over here in a
mitochondrial matrix where they can go
undergo beta oxidation now this process
in particular transporting these a so co
a s across into the medical andrew
matrix this process is rate limiting
for beta-oxidation and what do I mean by
that well it determines how fast
beta-oxidation can actually occur and
the reason why is because the
mitochondria can only oxidize as much a
Sequoia as there is available in the
matrix to oxidize so the enzymes of
beta-oxidation are in the mitochondrial
matrix and if there's a soak away is
available it's going to act on them but
the the process of beta oxidation is
only going to happen as fast as the
availability of acyl Koei's allows for
so if this transport system if this
transport system continually transport
acyl transports acyl Koei's into the
mitochondrial matrix then beta oxidation
will happen more often if it's
transporting them will be slower then
beta oxidation can only move as fast as
this transport system allows okay so we
mentioned before previously in the
enzyme videos about enzyme regulation is
that regulated enzymes are either the
enzymes that catalyze the first
committed step of a pathway or they
catalyze an irreversible reaction or
they catalyze the rate limiting step and
in this case this process like the
transporting the isoko ways into the
mitochondrial matrix cytoplasm is rate
limiting for the pathway of beta
oxidation so if this process is rate
limiting then it must be regulated and
it is so let's talk a little bit about
that so the regulation of fatty acid
oxidation right specifically beta
oxidation the regulated protein or
enzyme is um the carnitine acyl
transferase one right cat one
so cat one you'll notice is really the
first role player in this pathway right
it's it's the the first enzyme that you
know creates this acyl carnitine so
every other role player comes later
right the the translocase comes after it
and a cat 2 comes after it so it makes
sense that the first one is going to be
regulated now I'm going to tell you the
the molecule that regulates this enzymes
activity is Melanie Alcoa now I don't
think we've talked about Melanie Wilco a
much but we will in the future with
fatty acid synthesis specifically
Melanie Ocoee is the molecule that's
committed to fatty acid synthesis now
knowing that what do you think will
happen to cat 1 if Melanie Ocoee the
molecule committed to fatty acid
synthesis is the molecule that regulates
this thing's activity how do you think
Melanie Kawai will affect carnitine
acyltransferase one
well if Melanie Alcoa is the molecule
committed to fatty acid synthesis and
this cat one is involved in giving fatty
acids to be broken down then Melanie
Ocoee must inhibit carnitine
acyltransferase one and that should make
sense why does that make sense well we
shouldn't have fatty acid breakdown and
fatty acid synthesis happening in the
same cell at the same time if Melanie
Alcoa is committing to fatty acid exists
we want fatty acid synthesis to occur
not fatty acid break down if you want
fatty acid breakdown to occur
we don't want fatty acid synthesis to
occur so if Melanie okole is available
and that's the committed molecule
fethiye since that's definitely going to
stop fatty acid breakdown from occurring
and it stops it by inhibiting by
inhibiting this enzyme right here from
even creating these acyl carnitine
so I hope you found that video helpful
and kind of understanding the carnitine
mediated transport of acyl Koei's thank
you for watching